foreign
[Music]
you to this section on new approaches in
the genetics of disease and today I'm
here to talk about advances in high
throughput proteomics using NGS as a
readout
I have a member of the marketing team at
o-link proteomics and you might say well
this is a genetics of disease why are we
talking about proteins well I'm glad
you're here
today's outline we'll talk a little bit
about o-link and the context of the
challenges of 21st century health care
and there are plenty of challenges that
remain in particular one of scale
because we're used to looking things
almost like genomics in 2000 or 1999
when you're looking at a single
a nucleotide polymorphism on a scale of
dozens or maybe a hundred and you'd say
well how can we take a look at a hundred
thousand how can we take a look at a
whole exome's worth of mutations we have
a similar challenge of scale with
protein analysis as well
and then I'll finish with three
practical applications of this
technology
which is looking at Alzheimer's looking
at multiple sclerosis and looking at
drug discovery
now a little bit about o-link
so o link is a worldwide organization
with many top uh customers founded in
uppsala Sweden and then having presence
in Boston and the Far East in particular
Shanghai Tokyo and Singapore
another uh thing I'd like to point out
from this slide is there are over 800
peer-reviewed Publications on the
platform only God it's start in 2004
however uh it was not until about
2015 2016 that all link started
commercializing a 96 Plex uh protein
assay that we currently call o-link
Target 96.
um this climate peer-reviewed
Publications has recently spiked upward
with greater and greater interest in
circulating proteins uh in serum and
plasma as biomarkers and in particular
uh most recently the combination of
genetic variation data with circulating
protein biomarker data for drug
Discovery and for looking at mechanisms
of disease
the last thing I'll point out on the far
right is consortia in that there are
several Global Consortium one or two of
which I'll mention in this talk later
and as far as uh you know this
particular slide Global relationships
local Laboratories and proudly Swedish
the term proudly Swedish may be a bit of
a misnomer because I think Swedish folks
in my understanding of them and my
friendships with them they tend to be a
self-effacing group but nonetheless you
know uppsala may sound familiar uh
because as a matter of fact it was in
Sweden and Stockholm that Eliza's were
first invented back in the 60s it is
where uh cross-linked cephedex was
invented
um forming a company called pharmacia
for you Old-Timers out there you may
remember pharmacia in the late 90s for
bioprocessing and chromatography now
uppsala still has a large presence from
saitiva which is the GE Healthcare right
which acquired Pharmacy uh ammersham
those kind of companies and then they
still have a large presence in uppsala I
was just there last week and usala it's
just a small City relatively small 150
000 or 170 000 or so people but it's
remarkable in terms of the amount of
protein expertise the amount of
understanding of different Technologies
and as you can see from the icons and
Below we have customers uh Global
worldwide
now this particular slide illustrates
the picture of 21st century Healthcare
and you don't have to go back okay well
you have to go back 20 years to essays
that were written in 2000 and 2001 about
the promise of the Human Genome Project
and how it was felt that uh the
diagnosis and the development of
medications was going to just
revolutionize health care we're going to
cure diseases we're going to be able to
understand so much through the Human
Genome Project
yet 20 years later or 22 years later I
mean the map was announced in the
Lincoln room of the White House you can
look up that particular speech it's
remarkable you have Craig Venter sitting
on one side of Bill Clinton then you
have Francis Collins sitting on the
other side of Bill Clinton and Clinton
talking about you know the most wondrous
map that mankind has ever produced the
map of the human genome this is 2000 the
year 2000 and then naturally uh 2001
the two Landmark papers in Nature and
Science you know with the first draft of
the human genome it was very very
exciting certainly for those of us who
are involved in science at that time
extremely exciting times but what has
happened in the last 20 years in terms
of all the genomics that have taken
place there have been tens of thousands
right of genomide Association studies to
look at uh inherited risk for common and
for rare disease and you can say you
know the Human Genome Project has
certainly benefited monogenic mendelian
disorders and so we're looking at out of
I think something like 7 000 in Omen in
terms of mendelian disorders inherited
disorders in man
uh only about half of them have a clear
genetic you know we've identified the
genetic components and then a fraction
of that are uh druggable and or there's
some sort of therapy you can do around
it so certainly in the realm of rare uh
monogenic disorders uh the Human Genome
Project has been just wonderful another
area where the Human Genome Project has
revolutionized Healthcare I point to
cancer the development of targeted
therapies about 42 percent of phase one
phase two and phase three cancer drugs
that are going through clinical trial
Improvement now are targeted therapies
that is looking at the molecular
characterization mainly DNA aberrations
uh in the from the patient's tumor
samples to guide treatment and having
therapies against those molecular
alterations so that is another area
where the 20th century 21st century
Healthcare has been fundamentally
changed through the Advent of genomics
I'd say a third one that impacts sort of
the modern uh the modern person I
remember certainly when I had my first
child we had to go through amniocentesis
it was invasive we had the known risk of
about a one percent risk of miscarriage
in doing this diagnostic test for the
health of the fetus
now it's been completely replaced
through non-invasive prenatal testing or
nipt and this is where circulating uh
blood DNA right is able to pick up on
shedding fetal DNA and acid for uh for
Trisomy now you look at moderate in
terms of RNA and naturally right with
the Advent of RNA vaccines you know that
is a huge huge opportunity and
breakthrough right through this pandemic
there are certain rna-based drugs either
RNA interference or using other RNA
mechanisms short
interfering rnas and what have you
however you know the learnings from all
the RNA work and rnac can transcriptome
work has been moderate right in terms of
either rna-based Diagnostics or
rna-based Therapeutics
now looking at proteins naturally
proteins are the Workhorse of biology
when you think about everything from
structural proteins to enzymes that
replicate DNA that of course transcribe
it into RNA and and of course you know
as far as the proteins that are doing
anything in a Cell right this is where
the um uh the the action occurs
and when you look at for example FDA
Diagnostics there are over 200
diagnostic tests that are based around
proteins in terms of measuring protein
levels so and then even the vast
majority of drug targets okay in terms
of pharmaceuticals they are working
against protein targets that's on the
order of 95 96 of all drug targets are
proteins
so as far as o-link right why scientists
use oiling products to measure proteins
and the upper right and the darkest
section is a better understanding of
biology
scientists looking at just circulating
proteins can understand biology on a
real-time basis they are looking at you
know panels of proteins for people that
are risk for heart failure uh we have uh
customers who are working in diabetes
and they are understanding the risk for
uh kidney failure through their samples
and through their sample cohorts if by
circling around on the right predicting
disease and outcomes right so our
pharmaceutical customers are looking at
being able to determine the outcome
based upon blood biomarker signatures
patient stratification there is an
example of interstitial lung disease
where you can determine which patients
will actually
have progressing fibrosis for
Progressive fibrosis in an interstitial
lung disease example and other patients
that will not and using that to stratify
your patient population in the clinical
trial has the potential to save about
one-fifth I'm sorry you can say you can
use one-fifth of the patient samples
only 20 percent saving 80 percent of the
value of the cost of doing that
particular trial
there are surrogate markers for safety
and efficacy naturally great interest to
drug Discovery and wellness from Health
to disease there have been some
fascinating Wellness longitudinal
studies that is taking a population to
individuals simply taking their blood at
regular intervals and then being able to
track the individuals who remain healthy
and the individuals who declined into
different kinds of disease and these
kinds of longitudinal studies are
extremely extremely powerful as one
example
uh researchers at The Institute of
systems biology in in Washington state
had a spin-off company called araval
they followed several hundred
individuals who were healthy over a
course of several years and they were
regularly taking blood samples well
three of these individuals developed
Advanced metastatic Cancers and it's
awful right that the when you think
about the individuals involved However
the fact that these individuals who got
these Advanced Cancers and were
diagnosed with these Advanced cancers
you had
pre-diagnostic cancer samples you knew
this person was developing say stage
four pancreatic cancer which there are
very very few reliable biomarkers and of
course very very poor treatment and
prognosis the fact that you can that
they had the pre diagnostic blood
samples from people who ended up getting
a horrible disease they can now look
into those pre-diagnostic samples and
determine what was different and the
paper published in nature Communications
revealed three remarkable markers that
were
very solid and very statistically
significant markers
that had not been characterized before
as early detection markers for advanced
metastatic disease and so not only is a
pancreatic cancer it was also lung
cancer and one other now this slide
describes the complete drug development
process which our customers and Pharma
take advantage of they use it for
discovering drug targets and that first
minor point in terms of protein
quantitative trait loci they're actually
identifying proteins with strong
evidence of causality using the genetic
background of the individual the
circulating level of the protein and the
disease state in order to ferret out the
causal protein for that disease state it
uses a method called mendelian
randomization as it is and it is an
extremely powerful tool on the Discovery
side only now is able to detect 3 000
protein biomarkers and it is uh quite a
powerful tool to be able to have this
broad screen of understanding the
underlying biology as a for example
right where in pre-clinical research and
you really want to understand the
mechanism of action in terms of the
particular molecular question for
therapy you're able to see the
perturbation in the circulation of the
circulating proteins and being able to
match that against your the model in
existence of what the mechanism of drug
action is
you can see through phase one with
safety phase two efficacy you know the
large majority is something on the root
of half right of all clinical trials
fail just due to efficacy so being
unable to show that the drug in question
that's in development is able to provide
benefit to the patient
an interesting story on the post-market
surveillance even after approval
we have customers who take a look at
those samples that were collected during
the clinical trial to give them Clues as
far as how that particular drug that's
on market for one indication can be used
for other indications and you might say
well how does that work you say well
okay they see the pattern right of the
proteins that are perturbed they
understand more of its mechanism of
action they say well this particular
proteins are being down regulated and
these other proteins are being
upregulated that seems like an ideal
candidate for this other disease that we
hadn't thought about before then they
can take the existing approved drug for
one indication and go back and say let's
take a look at this and start at phase
two because we already know the safety
profile of this particular drug now
we're going to see if it's efficacious
against this other indication so this
can be an extremely powerful tool in the
hands of a pharmaceutical customer
like I mentioned in the discovery side
only now has the capability to look at 3
000 proteins
and we're also then to verify in larger
numbers of samples using panels of 96
proteins and in terms of down to the
laboratory developed test and the future
in vitro in vitro diagnostic we have a
custom panel that's only 21 proteins we
have a customer in San Francisco called
octave bioscience and they're aiming to
revolutionize the way multiple sclerosis
is handled and taken care of and the
beauty of what they're doing is that
they have
developed a screen first they screen
1400 proteins against their uh patients
with MS of different different statuses
they're able to develop a multiple
sclerosis disease activity test that's
able to better uh characterize patients
that have subclinical progression and
that is the current status of multiple
sclerosis is you take an MRI with a
tracing agent and oftentimes it's
catching the progress of multiple
sclerosis after it's progressed too high
what they're doing is they're finding a
lower level of disease progression using
a circulating biomarker assay developed
in conjunction with all Link in terms of
Discovery and then validating their
results in both analytically for
laboratory developed tests and with
multiple sclerosis patients
the historical challenges in proteomics
has been a lack of sensitivity and the
lack the lack of throughput so this
combination that you can either have
high sensitivity and low throughput or
you can have high throughput and low
sensitivity on top of this High sample
consumption for example a competing
platform may only offer 10 proteins at a
time but it consumes 50 to 100
microliters of sample that can be an
issue dynamic range will proteins have a
12 logarithm range of high abundance to
low abundance proteins
the data analysis the cost and
particularly lack of specificity It's
Not Unusual for someone to do a
multiplex uh bead-based assay and have
to do experiments and duplicate or
triplicate just because of the
variability in the results
I'll go into how the uh proximity
extension assay works but we've overcome
these technical challenges with the
technology that has very very good
specificity due to the use of two
antibodies instead of one extremely high
sensitivity down to the femtogram per ml
range and on top of that there's this
dynamic range that covers 10 logarithms
from 50 grams to milligrams we use very
small amounts of sample
um it's really less than 10 microliters
is needed for a 3000 Plex assay very
high throughput the assay is set up in
96 well plates it is designed with high
throughput and liquid handling
Automation in mind
it's the scalability like I just
mentioned validation if you go to
olink.com you'll be able to find the
validation data for each of our 3000
targets and there's over 800
peer-reviewed Publications like I
mentioned
so I'd like to share with you a movie
that illustrates the proximity extension
assay via an animation
and so
so what we have is matched pairs of
antibodies that each have a unique
bar-coded DNA strand covalently attached
to it when you have two correct
antibodies recognizing the target the
naturally the Watson Crick hybridization
can take place we use an enzyme to
extend the DNA which adds the
specificity and this DNA strand that's
been extended now is the template for a
readout here in this case the readout is
real-time PCR now you can understand the
same process moving forward with NGS
where instead of the
count on an Illumina sequencer so this
is just showing uh sequencing by
synthesis but nonetheless we have a
digital signal that corresponds to the
protein concentration in each sample and
because of the way we're able to barcode
the identity of the antibodies right in
in terms of the antibody pairs we're
able to identify the protein and due to
other barcoding that happens in the well
we're able to identify this sample in
this particular library of molecules
and as far as then our ability to screen
lots and lots of proteins right we have
gen we have screened over 10 000 assays
all right a generic pool of antigens
there's a second pool with expanded
sense of antigens then we verify right
against cross-reactivity
so this uh basically a library of 3 000
different protein assays we know exactly
what we're measuring which is an
important point because there are
alternatives on the market that just
show patterns or will give you signal
without the full understanding of what
exactly it is you're measuring however
here in the only case we have three
thousand whose identity is very well
characterized
now this next slide illustrates the
plasma proteome and I mentioned there
were some 12 logs of dynamic range
between the most abundant proteins on
the upper left and then the least
abundant proteins on the lower right and
as the illustration shows our scope
covers the entire range of traditional
top-down proteomics using mass spec as
well as a low abundant proteins that
traditionally have been the province of
amino acids and the way we're able to do
oh I think one of the interesting things
from this chart is the top 22 proteins
in this chart
are comprised 99 of the mass of proteins
in a particular patient sample so it's a
really difficult problem right to be
able to either deplete those proteins or
verification data of correlation to
clinical immunoassays for three common
um uh markers across different platforms
from Roche and from r d systems and they
correlate very very well in terms of I
understand the o-link assay was one of
96 in this particular example and we're
looking at uh 96 plaques and the
measurement of these three different
proteins in the context of single Plex
allisas and naturally lyses are
considered the gold standard
the correlation of mass spectroscopy you
see how a spectrometry you see how close
it is in terms of overlay and this
represents 170 different samples
in terms of the platform like I
mentioned we have a 3000 on the high end
for Discovery we got panels of 96 and
one for cytokines at 48 and a real-time
Insurance that's associated with the uh
midplex or this 96 uh
Multiplex Amino assay as well as a
custom Focus for 21 like I mentioned
before
just a little bit about the panels right
we have uh these 33 000 divided into
eight panels of 384
and then we have a 14 or 14 human panels
plus a 15th for a mouse of 92 assays a
piece this is what we call Target 96.
I think one aspect of all link that is
not mentioned very often is the fact
that we have a data science team that is
dedicated to supporting our customers
for the data analysis from quality
control through data visualization and
statistical analysis
also for customers who want to do their
own analysis we have our packages as
well as online tools for statistics and
for generation of nice visual plots that
you can just drop into a manuscript or
publication
in this slide you can see the 19 protein
model for Alzheimer's disease
classification
outperforms the classic markers and at
the top you can see the classic marker
ATN in yellow for the discovery cohort
that particular agency was only 87
percent whereas the 19 proteins offers a
98 AUC which is remarkable right and not
a significant difference when you add
the ATN plus the 19 proteins on the
bottom validation cohort similarly 88
AUC for the ATN but you have a 96
percent
ASC using the 19 protein model
remarkable this is I believe it can be a
game changer for Alzheimer's disease
detection as in particular early
detection and stratification of the
patient population
this is the most comprehensive
characterization looking at 1400
plasma proteins and for Alzheimer's
disease and being able to discriminate
patients from healthy controls right in
two separate cohorts
and it also offers opportunities for
drug Discovery drug development
I mentioned in my prior remarks about
octave we'll just cover this very very
briefly
um as far as what octave did was look at
1400 proteins drill down into an 18 Plex
disease activity test that covers four
key aspects of the disease biology and
there are particular results like I
mentioned there'll be uh launching this
particular test to the multiple
sclerosis Community later this year and
I'll be very very exciting to watch
my the last example covers a Consortium
called scallop this is Andrew's
malarstig from Pfizer and from
carolinska Institute who is organizing
an effort called the systematic and
combined analysis of o-link proteins
and this is combining genomic variation
with disease status and the circulating
proteome and if you look on the cartoon
on the right you have the disease
individuals you've got the proteins the
disease and the genetics and then you
have drug targets so the goal of scallop
is to combine genomic variation
information of the individuals with
their circulating proteome and then to
be able to determine drug uh strong
candidates for drug targets
and this particular paper published in
late 2020 genomic and Drug Target
evaluation of 90 cardiovascular proteins
in 30 000 individuals what this study
did was take a look at a single Target
96 panel and combine 15 different
collaborators within the scallop
Consortium and what they ended up
finding was truly remarkable
this is a busy slide but nonetheless the
opportunity was to identify protein
quantitative trait loci and use a method
called mendelian randomization to
provide strong or intermediate causal
evidence for new drug targets and as you
may or may not know it takes a long time
to develop a drug today and it's
extremely expensive about 2.6 billion
dollars all right what is the results
the result is in green
we identified two proteins 11 proteins
not previously targeted with causal
evidence
of involvement in human disease right
this is causative proteins that are new
drug targets they identified in blue a
whole collection okay of proteins for
Target validation
and in purple they identified targets
for repurposing and Target mediated
safety
so for drug Discovery this is I mean one
paper cannot capture all the value in it
all right they looked at 30 000
individuals 85 proteins and 450 pqtls
and each of those 85 proteins right had
a positive associations for causality of
different disease types so I invite you
to go ahead and take a look at this
paper take a look at the supplemental
information take a look at table seven
in the supplemental information that
gives you all the details of these 85
different genes
and lastly we'll mention the Pharma
proteomics project this is a project in
collaboration with the UK biobank where
the there were 10 Pharma uh Partners who
have sponsored this to take a look at 50
000 samples of the UK biobank again
these are individuals from 2006 to 2010
a total of 500 000 individuals who have
consented to not only have their genome
sequenced but also their blood samples
and their uh infra health information
recorded by the UK biobank so as time
goes on the UK biobank becomes more and
more valuable as these individuals
unfortunately will get sick and
unfortunately right will be treated but
nonetheless the genetic backgrounds will
be known the blood samples will be taken
like I mentioned those you know pre
diagnostic cancer samples will be
obtained and it's going to be a
remarkable remarkable project so the UK
biobank has already moved on to the
Explorer 3K they're looking at 53 000
samples from the UK biobank okay with 3
000 circulating proteins where the
genomic information is known or the
circulating proteome information is
known and the phenotypes the disease
states are known and this method called
mendelian randomization can use be used
to combine genomic data circulating
proteome levels and the phenotypes for
new drug Discovery truly exciting after
nine months of exclusivity the Pharma
Partners have agreed right to make all
their data public
and in terms of current timing it's now
April of 2022 by the end of 2023 the end
of next year you're going to see a
remarkable explosion coming out of this
particular project combining genomics
combining proteomics and
combining a a combination a wide variety
of disease states to truly understand
right opportunities for precise targeted
treatment
why this matters
this matters because we have a faster
and broader discovery of new drug
targets that are likely to succeed
this matters to significantly reduce the
cost and time to Market and Drug
development
and it's going to benefit humanity and
the future of Health Care as patients
get access to efficient drugs faster
I want to thank you very much for your
time and attention be happy to entertain
any questions or comments
and I appreciate it